how's everybody doing
today I've been inspired to do something
a little bit different due to the
criminally poor box office this weekend
of an edge of tomorrow in America it
opened at number three behind Fault in
Our Stars at number one and Maleficent
at number two new movies doing fairly
well internationally but in America it
is considered at this point a bomb this
is a film that has been lauded
universally by critics and fans and
audiences are eating this movie up I
loved it I thought it was extremely
surprising and I am very inclined to
share with you guys five reasons why it
is actually important that you see edge
of tomorrow now if you agree with me on
these reasons I implore you to share
this video with your friends share it
with people so that we can get the word
out on this incredibly awesome movie
before it flies completely under the
radar and people don't see it number one
it's based off of manga edge of tomorrow
is an adaptation of the manga all you
need is kill I love manga I'm a fan of
anime if you can't tell I grew up
watching anime I'm a humongous fan of
Japanese animation I think it is a
untapped artform in America where
Americans just there they're like I
don't know like what's that all about
you know how in the world when they find
like an oil source on an island
somewhere and they're like oh my gosh
look at all this untapped oil that we
didn't know about all this potential
that to me is anime they give it chances
every once in a while they're like well
we'll think about doing that adaptation
of that show or we'll think about maybe
reading that manga that so many people
are saying is good but I think we'll
just make another stupid romantic comedy
that's horrible that makes a lot of
money there are so many great stories
out there that are waiting to be adapted
things like ghost in the shell' I would
cry if there was a good ghost nichelle
adaptation there is so much awesome
potential there or cowboy bebop could
you imagine how great it would be if we
got a live-action cowboy bebop that was
actually really good
probably fantastically adult anime
perfect blue what if we got an
adaptation of this oh wait a second we
already do my point is is that Hollywood
took a chance
this film they adapted a manga how
awesome is that and they actually did it
with care they did a good job I mean we
get a lot of adaptations of comic books
and graphic novels because comic book
films are huge nowadays but rarely
anymore do we get a film adapted from a
manga that's actually done really well
because one of the last times that
Hollywood adapted a manga it really it
didn't work out and Hollywood pays
attention to this they will look at this
film and its success and say you know
what we don't want to adapt those other
mangas that we have potentially thinking
about because that doesn't do well in
America they don't like that and yet
millions of anime and manga fans across
the internet are pleading for a really
good movie based off of manga here we
have one and no one's seeing it number
two
Tom Cruise look love him hate him you
wait why would you hate him he didn't do
anything to you in all honesty though
Tom Cruise has been making great movies
for three decades I mean just listen to
this list the outsiders risky business
Top Gun the color of money Rain Man born
on the 4th of July a few good men the
firm interview with the vampire the
Mission Impossible movies Jerry Maguire
Eyes Wide Shut Magnolia Minority Report
The Last Samurai collateral Tropic
Thunder Valkyrie Jack Reacher this guy
has been making entertainingly awesome
movies for three decades you gotta give
it up for that and he gives it his all
in this movie he does a great job with
the stunt work and one of the things I
did not mention in my original review is
the fact that his character has a
serious arc in this movie he plays a
coward in this film and none of the
trailers marketed that he plays a
deserter he doesn't want to go to war
he's forced to he actually tries to
blackmail the person who orders him to
go to the frontlines and so as you get
to see his character progress and as he
learns how to be a soldier it's
extremely satisfying as a character arc
number three Emily Blunt she was
fantastic in this film and I'm not even
gonna talk about the fact that she gave
a good performance that her performance
had weight that she was good in the
action scenes I'm going to talk about
something extremely important
something in Hollywood is paying
attention to they're paying attention to
you they want to know how you react to a
strong female role that's actually
strong one of my least favorite movies
so far this year has been the other
woman a film that was billed as a female
empowerment movie but all the women ever
do throughout this film is talk about
men and how much they need men and how
they can't survive without men and let's
get back at men because we need men and
oh they did us wrong
they put Kate Upton in the film so we
could have some slow-mo close-ups of her
boobs bouncing up and down so they could
hopefully get some men to come to the
movie - that was the biggest lie of a
female empowerment movie I have ever
seen in my life it actually made women
look bad emily Blunt's character in this
film does not require men to be strong
she is strong on her own people look up
to her she's the puzzle piece that Tom
Cruise absolutely needs without her he
has nothing she actually trains him how
to be a soldier this is a strong
independent woman who actually kicks ass
in the movie and she is great at it
where are the women show up for her man
go to the movie pay a ticket and support
that thing number four it's not a
prequel a sequel or a franchise movie
nowadays we are bombarded by sequels and
prequels to everything everything that
ever happened that was successful once
has to have a prequel television show or
a spin-off movie or a franchise starter
this is an original film that is based
off as I said a Japanese manga how often
do we get that that's rare we need to
support this type of original filmmaking
in Hollywood where they attempt to show
a awesome blockbuster for movie nerds to
go to and actually have their brains
interact with it because it's a smart
film it's an enjoyable well-made film
and it doesn't try to latch itself on to
another piece of entertainment that's
already out there this is its own thing
we are constantly begging people in
Hollywood to make movies that are
awesome and here is one this movie is
really cool and different and original
and we've got to stand up for that and
number five it's actually really
freaking good edge of tomorrow
our is one of my favorite films that has
been released so far this year and I
know that it will be on my best of list
when this year ends because it's already
really dang high this is a film that is
directed with a lot of passion the
action sequences are enthralling there's
a great sense of urgency to the final
act in this film it never gets old
it never feels repetitious despite the
continuing string of scenes that we've
seen over and over again they found ways
to infuse humor and different aspects to
the scene that made it more interesting
to watch the characters are interesting
in the film the characters have a good
arc in the film as I said there's a
strong female role in this movie cruises
character has a great and satisfying arc
the action is awesome and doug liman did
a balls-to-the-wall fantastic job at
directing this movie I've gotten a few
tweets that have been like Chris are you
in the marketing team for edge of
tomorrow because all you do is talk
about how awesome it is look I do this
because I love movies I talked to you
guys about movies because I love movies
if I see a movie that I think is worth
your time that I love that I want to buy
on blu-ray the second it comes out that
I will go to Walmart Monday at midnight
and ask them to bring it out from a
cardboard box and hand it to me I am
going to talk about it I will sing to
the high heavens about it because this
is why I do what I do you guys got a
GoSee edge of tomorrow if you saw it if
you loved it as much as I did share this
video with your friends I want to spread
this video across the internet I want to
help this movie be more successful and
if I have any hand in doing that I will
be greatly satisfied guys thank you so
much for watching I just wanted to do
this because this is something I felt
very passionate about whenever I loved a
movie that doesn't do well at the box
office I want to help support it and if
you didn't check out my on film
criticism video my last video I just did
it had a lot of awesome guest stars I
think will be very excited to see the
schmoes know were involved Jeremy Jones
was involved
Scott mance from Access Hollywood was
involved how awesome was that please
check that out if you didn't have a
chance to it's on my channel right now
as always guys thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck Munoz